freunde der sonne nach high and welcome
at work es gibt mal wieder neuland wenz
kalender auszuprobieren und für die
leute die sich jetzt schon beschweren es
werden noch so viel mehr kommen aber für
alle die genau so geil darauf sind wie
ich geht's euch gut es gibt für den
adventskalender und zwar ganz kalender
von just spices wie immer ich habe mir
diesen adventskalender selber gekauft
ich bin nicht gesponsert ich habe keinen
kontakt zu jazzpreises wir haben keine
kooperation geplant oder sonst etwas
klicken einfach nur privat gekauft
tatsächlich weil das weiß es sich dieses
jahr dachte wir werden doch vor allen
anderen und dann ab ins gelände
rausbringt waren halt früh dran genauso
früh wieder hier im plan will kleben
aber darüber reden tatsächlich schon mal
der schwester von meinem freund
geschenkt und mich einzuschleimen und
ich glaube mittlerweile kennen so jeder
diese just bei ices gewürze ich bin
diese sicher wie ich den gleich testen
soll
ich werde glaube ich gewürz zu testen
ich bin gespannt was es da für gewürze
drinnen gehen und weil ich den
adventskalendern gestellt hat konnte ich
ihn sogar günstiger kaufen für 99 euro
statt 149 aber zuerst müssen ausziehen
[Applaus]
ich finde ihn sehr ansehnlich ist cool
dass der so rund ist also auch tisch auf
jeden fall schon mal richtig
ich meine ich habe dafür 100 euro
ausgegeben also hatte er optisch auch
ich wollte den halt schon letztes jahr
testen und so aber ich dachte mir halt
ja das sind halt gewürzt so was soll man
da testen
dann haben wir so viele leute in die
kommentare geschrieben problem an die
jobs von sculley dann dachte ich
probiere jeden scheiß und dann fangen
wir mal an ein türchen nummer eins
zahlen sind auch voll so also man sieht
die zahl hört nicht auf den ersten blick
da ist doch schon immer ein
kartoffelroder trautmann gewürz für
canto vergiss fades pellen und
langweilige knollen der kartoffel oder
verleiht deinen liebsten
kartoffelgerichten pikante würze also da
ist denn mehr als rote zwiebeln
knoblauch rus bin geräuchertes salz
paprika pulver rosa beeren geschrotet
schnittlauch solchen pfeffer schwarz
gemeint peter sie senden wir koriander
gemein marquis blüte gemeint war das
weil sie das sehe ich will ein kartoffel
gesicht werden
ein kartoffelgericht möchte ein zweites
gesicht werden gerade auch dass ich
danach voll wie die gewürze haben werde
probieren manchmal so schrott
adventskalender aus davon habe ich am
ende nicht aber hier habe ich mal was
davon nicht mal ja ich gut
stellt euch mal vor allem in challenge
nur mit nein
wie man ein bisschen was aber richtig
gut
das kann ich mir richtig gut für welches
vorstellen aus dem ofen weil die weiß
ich immer nicht wichtig würzen soll man
so kann auch in klein schneiden mit ein
bisschen öl im ofen park dann ist das
glaube ich perfekt
2 ich tue auch sonst irgendwas anderes
außer gewürze erwartet die matsch
weißwein gewürz liebe weißen glühwein
liegt aber auch daran dass ich von
rotwein immer kopfschmerzen bekommen und
mir das immer sparen möchte erinnert
euch dieses video ist nicht gesponsert
und jetzt alle zusammen die hier ist
nicht schön oder
das riecht würzig also wir haben
orangenschalen sind blüten paradies
körner sternanis ingwer zitrone und wie
macht man das nur ein esslöffel das
reichte dann von lange ich dachte man
muss jetzt da die hälfte rein kippen
zuteil groh und sieht richtig cool aus 3
also nochmal zur verpackung ist er 40
ganz fantastisch unglaublich ganz toll
rausholen dieses video ist nicht
geschweige wird mehr salz pfeffer
paprika petersilie schnittlauch oha das
recht vor einer paprika und petersilie
der gute alte italien stollens weiß ich
kann euch ganz genau sagen wie es riecht
nach irgendeiner chips sorte es riecht
nach einer typs sorte ist auf jeden fall
sehr oregano lastig aber weil oregano
einfach sehr stark riecht finde ich also
dass
tomaten gurken paprika zwiebeln
basilikum und knoblauch oregano
petersilie
ich kann mir das perfekt vorstellen ohne
style ein brot tomate drauf und dann
dass dieses gewürz drüber und nunmehr 5
raclette geholt mein fähnchen das ist
die wahre sind gut haus zwiebeln
knoblauch tim janz dezimieren streue den
mix auf deine käse kreation und ab damit
in den raclette offen ist wie spezifisch
diese gewürze sind auch dein raclette
felchen ein raclette welchen es stimmt
aber wenn man raclette macht dann packt
man sich ja irgendwie gemüse drauf oder
ein stück fleisch oder schinken und käse
aber man wünscht es halt nie und es
schmeckt tatsächlich auch wenn ich mich
daran erinnern man schmeckt halt also
schmeckt halt die gewürz und wir sind am
donnerstag angegeben vielleicht
zelebrieren sie nikolaus mit fleisch und
braten gewürz für festliche fleisch
kreation und klassische sonntagsbraten
dieses wird die geheime zaubert die
extraportion aroma führender braten
stack und co als marinade oder witziges
finish über fleisch geben ziel in
pakistanischen kristall seines knoblauch
pfeffer tomaten flocken aber als ob ihr
euch das mal hören wollt ihr seid so wie
ich hier wollen vielleicht sehen
zum braten kann ich mir auf jeden fall
damit vorstellen steak habe ich jetzt
irgendwie nur mit salz und pfeffer kopf
frage mich ob man das auch über so
vegetarische alternativen packen könnten
ein des schnitzel steak würde so ein
explodieren wenn man das darauf macht
weit vorsichtig was ein glücksfall ist
die sie beschreibt in die kommentare
mediterrane gemüse allrounder ist das
gleiche wie italien stollens tomate
zwiebel mehrere klocke ja da sind andere
sachen drin für gemüse ja also das finde
ich auch wieder gut genauso wie mit den
ofenkartoffeln einfach ins gericht was
lecker schmeckt und ein bisschen
aufregender ist gemüse klein hacken aus
backblech und würzen und fertig ich hab
das gar nicht mehr probieren gerne
gewürze probieren nacht ein bisschen
schneller machen also auch wenn avocados
wirklich jetzt nicht das super gut sind
sind schon über wir wissen 1000 lieder
für eine avocado in sicht das größte
beste aber hier mit dem avocado topping
haben sie natürlich wieder eine avocado
liebhaber herz gewonnen kommen wie crazy
das aussieht was ist sich riecht aber
mehr salz blocken sesam schwarz ganz
tormann flocken pfeffer durch diesen
salzkristallen ist der größte seit
christa meines lebens falls ich wir
bilden auch so einem großen
salzkristallen kann also das muss ich
wirklich mal ausprobieren das hat mir
jetzt nicht so überzeugt jetzt kommt
meine lieblingszahl die nummer
und da wird jetzt auch mein lieblings
gewürzt und sein drittes beste gewürzt
aller zeiten das wird unser gewürzt
brain so weg pizza gewürzen ist ein
geiler base das pizza gewürz veredelt
selbst die gute alte tiefkühlpizza
knoblauch und zwiebeln majoran basilikum
bewirbt sich auch schon wieder so einen
italien augenbrauen darf nicht ist es
nicht sieht ganz anders aus
wer knoblauch lass dich wer knoblauch
lass dich bitte vorstellen mal ziehen
wie ein geld also die paar kombination
hier die gefällt wenn nicht ist doch
schon wieder knoblauch 32% knoblauch
raspeln lust aufs essen aber eine
schranke pasta habe jetzt hoffentlich
auch dass alle gewürze einfach die
gekochten nudeln mit etwas olivenöl und
mit unserem mix vermischen das riecht
nach knoblauch peter gehört da sind
viele tomaten flocken dazwischen also
ein richtiges trauriges single essen
oder einfach nur spaghetti kochen und
knoblauch darüber jetzt mein atem echten
feier in der nummer verbirgt sich heute
der kandidat nummer bratkartoffel
gewürzt aber ich hab doch jetzt schon
kartoffel allrounder raum reichte jetzt
noch einer kartoffel gewürz nur für
bratkartoffeln die zu laden voll gepackt
die frau vorne iconic
sie hören wir mal auf mit der groben
scheiße und zwar hier in pulver das
riecht das riecht nach schwimmbad pommes
ich finde es eher ruhig mal aufgefallen
wie krass gerüche erinnerungen triggern
können du kannst etwas riechen und bist
plötzlich zehn jahre in der
vergangenheit oder weil sie nicht in
deiner frühesten kindheitserinnerungen
weil irgendwas dich triggert das muster
krass in unserem hirn in seinem hirn
sind die ganze zeit alle erinnerungen
gespeichert und du musst noch immer
sehen oder riechen und schon kommt sie
nur bis zu
nummer zur halbzeit fähnchen gewürz
meersalz geräusche des saals rohrzucker
kann man ein hähnchen gehört kommt immer
zucker ein tomaten paprika und knoblauch
also leute da kann ja nicht viel zu
erzählen das riecht wie ein
grillhähnchen nummer 13
gemüsebrühe ohne zuckerzusatz um 40
prozent verkleinert das wurzelgemüse
also ich als polen hat natürlich wieder
im schrank ist gespannt das mithalten
kann
sehr lecker ohne zuckerzusatz finde ich
auch gut kann ich gleich pamela aufgeben
ist kein zucker oder ich hab das mal
gehört die ist kein zucker mit ist immer
so wenn ich eine limonade trinkt oder
irgendwas wo ich im nahen merkel
momentan ist auch wahrscheinlich zucker
38 gramm auch von der minute erfolg mein
erster gedanke war pamela wird das jetzt
nicht trinken und das ist
und hinkel moment jetzt wird es wieder
spannend café koßmann den kakao zimt
gemahlene regelungen bitte mach dein
liebstes heißgetränken noch
verführerischer und teils süße zwei
prisen im kaffeefilter heben die kaffee
einen aromen toll war der mann soll das
in den kaffee filterkaffee mit rein
geben und das hebt dann die erhoben
hervor
kaffee gibt muss es probieren
das muss ich wirklich ausprobieren leute
ich werde euch es gibt dinge die es gar
nicht 15
bei sami co dressing mix salat h das ist
ein salatdressing bin nämlich so
schlecht in salatdressing machen ja
nicht super aber wie ein bisschen wieder
und wieder drin ich habe ein problem mit
oregano wenn das irgendwo drin ist dann
richtig nur oregano pasta allrounder
also man kann es einfach so auf die
pasta machen oder man verfeinert einen
saucen kürze nummer 17 tonnen gewürz
schwarz gemein meersalz knoblauch
petersilie koriander
der bärlauch der macht es bestimmt wäre
ja das liegt ganz an das riecht nach dem
wald das hat auch super speziell da ich
meine natürlich kann man das auch
woanders rein machen aber es ist krass
dass man sich so nur für seine
pilzpfanne gewürz holt 18
jetzt fällt mir sorgen
da kam einfach kommen das hackfleisch
gewürz das hat mir noch gefehlt unsere
hackfleisch gewürzte bereit für seine
achse bei frikadellen gefüllte zucchini
ich werde für meine zucchinis benutzen
wir haben nämlich im urlaub frittierte
zucchini bälle gegessen und dann habe
ich ein gewürz dafür so lecker so sieht
es aus das wird perfekt sein
frikadellen schöne frikadellen geruch
19 kräuterquark
da habe ich auch ein super tipp aber es
kennen die wahrscheinlich schon wenn wir
immer so filmabende machen dann nehme
ich mal ein bisschen quark oder vegane
creme und macht dann so gewürze rein
aber ich habe noch keine gewürzmischung
dafür und dann ist das ein perfekter
denn für chips und paprikas und so dass
man so ein richtiger snack das riecht
nach lakritz nummern das 20
hat mit den pastor allrounder und das
polonaise wird und das sieht aber mir
auch wieder sehr ähnlich aus ich bin ja
gespannt ob ich die ganzen gewürze auch
auf brauchen werde und welches zuerst
leer wird wahrscheinlich der weise
glühwein ich meine dieses italienische
geschmack ist ja für unsere paprika dann
irgendwie auch ungarn und und 21 als
allrounder ich wusste nicht dass man
gewillt zu sein reich benutzen dann
reist heute zum superstar wird also es
sieht aus wie der intel reader oder
pasta oder reis allrounder dachte ich
jetzt vielleicht mehr sesam getrocknete
ein dass man das so ins japanische
bringt aber das ist wieder sehr
mediterran das ist mir in zu italien
laste die und da sind wir in indien
angekommen das ist kein irgendwie indien
rounder oder so sondern nur irgendwie
verbindet man mit curry immer indien
sofort ja schaut einmal wie viele
gewürze in seinem indien gehört ist ja
steht dir keine curry flanke curry ist
ja diese ganzen zu sein
falls ihr den anime footballs nicht
kennt da gibt es einen schüler an dieser
schule der ist quasi so dieser gewürz
spezialist und dann holt er immer seine
gewürze raus und curry und das ist wenn
man so sorgte aber noch so mal 1000 muss
ich immer an ihn denken wenn ich curry
riechen oder sehen was verbirgt sich
hinter kandidatin nummer 23 ist topping
musste würzt ihr euren humus an wir
haben wir selbst gemacht es sieht schon
ein bisschen aus scheiße mein akku ist
alles was ich sagen wollte bevor mein
akku alle gegangen ist das sesam drin
und es sieht wieder aus wie der italien
mit sesam die zwiebeln paprika
kreuzkümmel gemeinden da irgendwie
geschrotet bin ich mal gespannt also
muss kenne ich eigentlich immer sehr
ungewiss oder vielleicht denke ich nur
dass es um gewürzt ist aber wir sind bei
türchen nummer 24 angekommen und
dahinter verbirgt sich damit ist er leer
elisas schoko bananen und ich weiß also
ein gewürz für opel und die batterie
geht schon wieder alle den nächsten coup
reingesteckt dabei war auch wieder denkt
ich glaube ich hatte das schon mal das
ist so ein braunes pulver und da
schmeckt mit mandeln kakao bananen
schlecker muss unbedingt oben machen und
viele leute wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wieder
[Musik]